latest on rihanna's partner asat rocky's
arrest and release
e.t has obtained his booking sheet which
lists asap's birth name as rakim mayer's
bail was set at 550 000
police who were spotted removing items
from asap's home say the 33 year old
faces a felony charge of assault with a
deadly weapon stemming from an alleged
incident back in november a source tells
e.t this arrest was not something asap
and rihanna saw coming every week is
something new i'm enjoying it i'm just
excited for what i don't know yet you
know
clearly this was a very orchestrated
strategic arrest by the police they both
executed a search warrant of his house
and made the arrest at the same time
legal expert rachel stockman says the
lapd followed a plan perhaps they didn't
want him to do anything to disturb
evidence perhaps they wanted to collect
his phone as for rihanna
according to multiple reports she was
with asap at the time of the arrest my
guess as a condition of bail the judge
will probably take away his passport
it's not the first time asap's been in
trouble with the law back in 2019 he
spent three weeks in the swedish jail
after a street fight that's when you're
like oh this is some
you know they gonna make an example out
of me that's what they did
asap was convicted and fined as for
yesterday's arrest his court date has
been set for august 17th and while his
legal team prepares for that actor
johnny depp dropped a few bombshells in
court testifying under cross-examination
that he did drugs with actor paul
bettany and singer marilyn manson we've
had cocaine together maybe a couple of
times pills right with marilyn manson i
once gave
marilyn manson a pill
so that he would
stop talking
so much
paul bettany is a good friend that
you've done drugs with right it's a
strange question paul bettany is a good
friend
yes you've done drugs with him yes i
have cocaine
right oh cocaine yes alcohol
alcohol yes and this is interesting is
amber trolling johnny with her courtroom
fashion on the first day of the trial
depp wore a gucci tie with a bee on it
heard wore an almost identical tie two
days later after johnny started wearing
his hair in a ponytail amber switched up
to a similar look and more twinning
today amber and johnny both in dark
three-piece suits
late this afternoon this video was
played in court it shows johnny upset
drinking and discovering that amber is
taping him
you got this going
all right